the imf has been talking about bitcoin
quite a bit it's interesting because
they also have a ton of other problems
there's two or three central banks
around the world that are failing
there's the russia ukraine conflict
playing out but still the imf continues
to talk about bitcoin so it's obvious
they're paying attention in their latest
global financial stability report they
talked a lot about bitcoin in there as
well so to start the imf talked about
capital markets and what they said was
that capital markets might become more
fragmented with possible implications
for the role of the us dollar and the
fragmentation of payment systems could
be associated with the rise of central
bank digital currency blocks but that's
not all that the imf was talking about
actually if we look at dennis porter
pulled out a great point the imf has now
declared that bitcoin mining will allow
countries to monetize their energy
resources outside of the financial
system they don't look at this as a
positive thing but in the bitcoin
community and nation states look at it
as a very positive thing dennis then
went on to explain that the imf also has
announced that bitcoin and the launch of
blockchain technology provided a digital
infrastructure to record value on a
distributed system open to everyone so
it's obvious that the imf understands
what bitcoin is how it works and what
the advantages are they may not like
those advantages because it may go
against some of their interests but
ultimately it is important that
regulators and organizations like the
imf around the world they're getting
educated they're paying more attention
they're devoting a ton of mental energy
to this and that usually means that they
understand what the technology is and
what the value is lastly if we look the
imf had one last point that regulators
in the united states and the uk among
others have urged firms in their
jurisdictions including the crypto asset
sector to increase vigilance with regard
to potential russian-sanctioned evasion
attempts now it's a cute story to think
that russians or anyone else is using
crypto to evade sanctions but there's
very little proof that that's actually
occurring even the u.s treasuries come
out and said it's not something that
they're worried about so ultimately what
we have to remember is that when you
have an open immutable ledger meaning
that your transaction is written into
history forever for anyone in the world
to audit criminals don't want to use
that system they still prefer to use
things like the us dollar or other fiat
currencies that are much less traceable
and provide a level of financial privacy
that just can't be replicated with a
public open immutable ledger the imf
spending more time on bitcoin it's not
really a surprise of course they're
gonna do this over time bitcoin has
taken the world by storm it's almost a
trillion dollar asset it's been
literally created a thin air by
volunteers on the internet nobody even
knows the real name of the person who
actually wrote the code this is one of
those things that the imf is left
scratching their head but over time i
predict that the imf is actually going
to get very positive on bitcoin they're
going to realize that their current path
is unsustainable and they're going to
realize that bitcoin is good for
business it's good for individuals it's
good for corporations it's good for
nation states and ultimately bitcoin's
going to be good for the imf as well
everyone needs a life raft that's
exactly what bitcoin does hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time